what's that you say overwatch has a new
hero well unless it's doofus I don't
want to hear about wait what's that
it is doom ffice what the hell are we
waiting for let's get this hero guide on
the road those names will be remembered
in case you haven't been keeping track
the Rocket punchy Nigerian is the latest
addition to the overwatch lineup and
he's been a long time coming ever since
the first hint of his existence a year
ago fans have been foaming at the mouth
for any kind of doofus info skyscraper
well he's here he's real and I'm going
to teach you how to play him but first
make sure to hit subscribe so you don't
miss any more overwatch videos alright
let's go I'll tell you right off the bat
doom fist might be one of the most
diverse damage dealers in the game his
assortment of abilities allows you to
get pretty creative with how you
approach enemy heroes and gives each
encounter a unique experience so let's
start off with the basics doom fist
primary fire is this hand cannon it's a
mid to long range shot gun blast that
deals a decent amount of damage but you
can only shoot it four times before it
needs to recharge this means you won't
be chasing people around and shooting
them much but I mean your name is doom
ffice emphasis on the fist part the hand
cannon should mostly be used to gain
some damage while you're waiting for
your other abilities to cool down
speaking of which
the rocket punch this is where doom fist
proves himself worthy of the name this
is where we separate the adults from the
children hold down the secondary fire
button to wind up the haymaker and
release it when you're fully charged or
when some poor soul walks in front of
you it'll deal a good amount of damage
stun them for a second and here's the
best part
slam them into a nearby wall for even
more damage aside from crushing enemies
into the sides of buildings the rocket
punch is also great means of
transportation a fully charged punch
will travel about 30 meters which is
just far enough for you to cross that
gap at honimaru the range on rocket
punch also means you'll be able to
charge people from a distance as it
travels much faster than reinhardt's
charge so use it to get in quick on your
enemies but my favorite way to use it is
to charge up as you're walking around
corners feeding a surprise knuckle
sandwich to anyone unfortunate enough to
be in your crosshairs just keep in mind
you can't aim the punch upwards or
downwards only parallel to the ground so
if that fara is annoying you doofus has
his rising uppercut to help you out use
this ability and he'll do his best for
you impression rocketing himself into
the air along with anyone else who
happens to be standing in front of you
it's a great melee attack but the
altitude you gain by performing it might
be the most important thing it gives
dufus an escape option which is pretty
crucial considering he has no other
defensive abilities and he only has 250
health but rising uppercut is only half
the story once you're in the air you can
continue the combo with seismic slam
which causes doofus to smash into the
ground knocking the enemies silly and
causing damage depending on how far your
slam traveled you'll be able to aim the
slam as a small cone will appear
whenever you're airborne indicating your
landing spot also the travel distance on
sighs next time has a deceptively long
range so if you're in a tight spot and
need to escape doing a risin uppercut
then the seismic slam at the very apex
of your jump will get you right the hell
out of Dodge put these three abilities
together and what have you got a deadly
combo that will lay waste to all but the
beefiest of beefcakes
oh by the way did I say that he has 250
health I meant 280 weight no three 325
actually 400 okay so what you see here
is his passive ability the best offense
in action for every hit that you land
with one of doom' disabilities you'll
gain a temporary 30-point shield and for
every hit you land with this ultimate
you'll get an additional 70 point shield
and his passive ability is what ties
everything together it encourages you to
constantly attack the other team use
your abilities at every opportunity and
be an all-around disruption
now it's entirely possible to play doom
fist defensively rock a punching your
way into the enemy team and then leaping
out with things get hairy but with some
of the most impressive tools in the game
I've got a feeling doofus will be a
staple in team comps for a while not
only is he the most anticipated hero to
date he's got the damage and skill set
to boot and finally do this ultimate
meteor strike using your ultimate will
shoot Dukas straight up into the air and
your reticle turns into a large circle
on the ground indicating your landing
spot now you'll have 5 seconds to move
that target around at which point you'll
come crash it back down earth dealing
damage and knocking back anyone that was
inside the circle the amount of damage
will depend on how close they were to
the center of your circle so try to
catch people while they're distracted by
other heroes or in an enclosed space
like a hallway or stairwell
also if you're really desperate you can
use it to get away during the ultimate
doom fyssas all the way up in the air
where nobody can target them so in an
emergency you can activate the old shoot
up into the sky and fly far away to
safety meteor strike is a great ultimate
to combo with other characters as well
like a may or Reinhardt or even get
Zarya to throw graviton surge first for
an easy couple of kills I know it's
still early on but dude this might
already be the most enjoyable and
satisfying character to use for me if
you crave short-range melee focus
fighters and we're waiting for a hero
with the tools to make it work doing
this is a perfect fit it might take you
a little bit of practice in order to
become fluent with his abilities but
like the fighting games that most
definitely influence doom fist design
your patience is rewarded with a
satisfying combo and hopefully a win for
you and your team and that's it I hope
you guys learned a thing or two about
doofus now if you guys have any
questions or tips or anything else you
want to say about doofus leave them in
the comments below and I'll try to get
to them and if you enjoyed watching this
video make sure to hit like and
subscribe to our channel and maybe even
check out the 24 other hero guys that we
have for the characters all right see
you guys next time
you